- I mean you can't call
that a baguette, really,
or you would be jailed in France.
(playful guitar strumming)
My name is Gus Reckel.
I'm the owner of L'imprimerie.
Being French, I've been
baking my entire life.
Today, we're gonna taste some
free bread from restaurants
all over America.
I'm very excited.
(lightly playful accordion music)
It's really light.
Soft, smooth, pillowy, that's good.
(sniffing)
It smells like buttery.
It's very, very, very dense.
It's almost briochey.
Did you bring cheese?
You did?
You didn't, no cheese.
No cheese, no butter.
Mmm.
It's not bad.
The flavor is good.
Texture from the outside is very nice,
and then it becomes
like almost too fluffy.
Very doughy.
We give like maybe two
stars to start with.
(lightly playful accordion music)
Red Lobster.
Beyonce called it in a
song, so it should be good.
It's very oily.
The cheese, I guess.
The biscuit is very dense.
(sniffing)
It smells like (sniffing)
there is like butter and herbs.
Mmm, um.
It's not very cheesy.
I think they look good.
On the shelf, I would pick one up.
Well, not this one.
But the other one was good.
Three stars because it's
free and cheesy and greasy?
(lightly playful accordion music)
It's very pillowy,
in a good way, but no crunch.
If you push it, it becomes mushy.
(sniffing)
It doesn't smell like anything really.
It does smell like warm bread.
Warm bread is always good.
Can take the rolls, whatever,
when it's warm, it's good.
Mmm, this is very sweet.
This is like sugar, or maybe
a bit of honey, or molasses.
It is so sweet.
It is pure sugar.
There goes my beach body.
Here comes the dad bod.
The flavor is okay.
More like a brioche.
I think, three stars for the effort.
It comes with butter to make it better.
Everything is better with butter.
(lightly playful accordion music)
Really soft.
That's a good thing.
That fact that it comes with the butter,
makes it more interesting.
(sniffing)
No yeast.
It's not unpleasant; now the inside.
We back to this mushy, airy.
Let's see how they taste.
Mmm, this one is very sweet too.
In a kind of good way,
but not in a way I was expecting.
This is a spread.
Gonna makes it even sweeter.
Yeah, no beach for me this summer.
Mmm.
It's not for me.
I would give maybe one star.
(lightly playful accordion music)
I think we're supposed
to have a brown one,
but I guess it's so good
that it got eaten on the way.
So we're going to try only this one.
Close as it looks to French bread,
let's see.
You could have a good surprise, maybe.
(knocking)
The sound is not too bad.
There's little fermentation
and little love.
Maybe the brown one was better,
but we don't have it, so.
(crackling)
Make some noise,
but it's more the noise
of like, stale bread.
It's very chewy and very hard.
Not hard as in crispy, just hard as in,
as in hard.
The crumb is okay.
Two stars because they
tried to do French bread,
but with maybe little success.
I like the idea that restaurants America
give bread to people.
I think what we would love to see is more
artisan bread everywhere.
French people, you know?
We're just sassy and
catty and (chuckling).
(lightly playful accordion music)